this week Google jumped into the AI arms
race with the launch of Bard the chatbot
will compete with openai's chat gbt
which is funded by Microsoft in a few
short months these chat Bots have wowed
users with the ability to answer
complicated questions draft emails and
speeches plan custom vacations and much
more but as it improves this technology
offers immense promise and significant
some say existential danger Brook Silva
Braga traveled to Toronto one of ai's
leading research hubs to meet some of
the people building this Brave New World
so yeah so this is a an experimental
preview of a chatbot we've been working
on powered by our generative language
model okay Nick Frost is a co-founder of
cohere like Google and openai the
Toronto startup has trained massively
powerful computers on trillions of words
and ask them to talk back can it write
call it a book report about War and
Peace okay it can War and Peace is a
historical novel by Russian author Leo
Tolstoy in a major leap for computing
these models can understand and create
natural language it just wrote this yeah
but it's based on all the stuff that
it's seen the tech had been in research
labs for years chat gpt's release last
fall cheese or cheese so luscious and
bold brought it to an unprepared public
it's writing me a poem about cheese and
it's pretty good in the old school
programming we would write code to tell
a computer or what to do we still do
that lots of people still do that but
another thing we do now is we write code
to tell a computer how to learn what to
do and the way it learns is being shown
many examples of what it should do so in
the context of large language models the
way that works is we get a huge amount
of text and then we show it a few words
and we get it to predict the next word
this simple technique turns out to give
you something very useful and very
powerful
so powerful that openai's new gpt4 does
better on the bar exam than 90 percent
of aspiring lawyers these models write
computer code in seconds and churn out
blog posts on any topic that AI
programmers haven't banned they're
becoming the newest Arbiters of what
ideas are out of bounds and while chat
apps are the current rage other forms of
AI now you can generate a video with
nothing but words we'll do much much
more this is the biggest technological
advancement since I think is comparable
in scale with the Industrial Revolution
or electricity electricity or maybe the
wheel
or maybe the wheel
yeah Jeffrey Hinton is known as a
Godfather of artificial intelligence for
the last 10 years he's helped Google
create Ai and Mentor the industry's
rising stars including open ai's Chief
scientist Ilya siskova and Nick Frost
over at cohere in fact Toronto is a
global AI Hub today in large part
because Hinton moved here 40 years ago
when the Canadian government agreed to
fund his unusual research I was kind of
wig because I did this stuff everybody
else thought was nonsense While others
pursuing AI tried to program logic and
reasoning into computers Hinton thought
it was better to have them figure things
out themselves the idea was to mimic the
brain with lots of practice these
virtual neural networks Illustrated here
would make the right connections to
solve a given task
there were doubters the big issue was
could you expect a big neural network
that learns by just changing the
strengths of the connections could you
expect that to just look at data and
with no kind of innate prior knowledge
learn how to do things people in
mainstream AI thought that was
completely ridiculous it sounds a little
ridiculous it is a little ridiculous but
it works it's all
the real
only in the last decade or so have
computers been powerful enough to prove
Hinton was right his machine learning
ideas applied to different kinds of
training data now create all kinds of
outputs this of course isn't Tom Cruise
but a deep fake impersonating him I went
down to the office because they're
making a robot of me this isn't Andy
warhol's voice in the recent Netflix
documentary but a clone generated by
resemble AI click record and then read
the sentence out loud after a few
minutes income between reading training
text it'll go ahead and build us in the
background founder zohab Ahmed had
cloned my voice too Habitat for Humanity
which helps homeowners build homes
alongside volunteers yeah I definitely
hear myself in there smile into the
camera a company called Synthesia had me
read a script in front of a green screen
they used that video to create this
digital version of me we paired it with
resembles voice to create a TV reporter
who will say anything you type
the technology will only get better in
the years ahead using this Tech to
spread misinformation seems inevitable
this is my very first day in zingwana's
agency using it to replace journalists
and lawyers and accountants and
Radiologists and novelists and
songwriters and Painters well that could
happen too but it's going to take a
whole ton of jobs I think it's going to
make a whole lot of jobs easier and a
whole lot of jobs faster I hear your
answer in two ways one
wow it's great if it turns out that way
two maybe it's a little scary if the
people making this technology haven't
come to graphs with the potential
downfall of what it could do yeah I
think we try our best to think about
what the true impact of this technology
is in the true impact of these
advancements is the subject of a
high-stakes debate right now will AI
quickly Zoom past human abilities and
become what's thought of as artificial
general intelligence or AGI last month
open AI CEO Sam Altman wrote the risks
could be extraordinary a misaligned
super intelligent AGI could cause
Grievous harm to the world
but Frost and others say Terminator
style worries are overblown large
language models are just algorithms that
write some smart sounding words they
don't understand even basic truths what
day is it it's Monday it's Monday it's
just yes it's just guess yeah I don't
think the technology we're building
today naturally leads to artificial
general intelligence I don't think we're
close to that his mentor used to agree
until quite recently I thought it was
going to be like 20 to 50 years before
we have general purpose AI now I think
it may be 20 years or less some people
think it could be like five I wouldn't
completely rule that possibility out now
and whereas a few years ago I would have
said no way are we close to the
computers coming up with their own ideas
for improving themselves yes we might be
and then it could just go fast that's an
issue right we have to
think hard about how to control that
yeah can we we don't know we haven't
been there yet but we can try okay that
seems kind of concerning
um yes what do you think the chances are
of AI just wiping out Humanity it's not
inconceivable okay that's all I'll say
how Hinton wonders will we manage a
technology that could give a handful of
companies or governments such awesome
power and so I think it's very
reasonable for people to be worrying
about those issues now even though it's
not going to happen in the next year or
two people should be thinking about
those issues
for CBS Saturday morning still writing
his own script for now Brook silver
Braga Toronto
good for you Brooke yeah yeah right but
two questions like why are you building
it one and two why aren't you thinking
about the possible impact it's the it's
this big question mark and and and the
rest of us have to deal with to try to
make life easy I thought the bigger
question was when Brooke asked what do
you think of the possibility of AI
wiping out exactly humanity and the guy
says it's not inconceivable yeah exactly
I mean my point exactly right I don't
think we can answer that in 10 seconds